it's Friday februari 26th but it's not
just any Friday it's canine Friday here
at CBS so I'm going to be counting down
the top five puppies of the week also
the new story the first puppy is clearly
the cutest it's mine this is C Mon the
digger he's going to win also in gaming
news our first story is all the free
xbox one and 360 games you get with your
gold subscription in march on xbox one
you get Sherlock Holmes crimes and
punishments that's march first through
the 31st you also get lords the Fallen
which is March 16th through april
fifteenth on 360 supreme commander two
is march first through the 15th and
borderlands march 16th through the 31st
in the meantime you can still pick up
February's free games these include hand
of fate and sticks master of shadows on
the Xbox one as well as gears of war two
for 360 note that 360 games with gold
titles are playable on Xbox one through
backwards compatibility so our second
puppy is Bochy he's a little cutie pie
and our second news story is the star
wars battlefront update that went live
this week here's everything at adds and
changes the new battlefront map is
Twilight on Hawk it's now playable on
the Walker assault supremacy turning
point fighting squadron drop zone and
heroes vs. villains game modes the new
mission is called survival in the ice
caves as for the new film grain setting
you'll find it in the game's video menu
in terms of weapon changes primary
weapons now do a ten percent extra
damage to air vehicles while barrage
damage has been increased from 50 to 55
there's been changes to the bow caster
explosion damage and they've increased
the size of a wing hit box on top of all
that when piloting the slave one you can
now see if a rebel vehicle has a shield
active through with a new icon that pops
up you'll get in the mattress faster
with a new battle for an update as free
round timer has been lowered from 30
seconds to 20 the patch also brings with
it a number of bug fixes including
solutions for lighting textures audio
user interface text and collision
problem
battlefronts first paid expansion outer
rim is coming in March at least three
other expansions will follow Bespin
Death Star and an untitled offering so
our third little puppy is named Stanley
and our third story if that Pokemon Sun
and Moon have been confirmed for the 3ds
coming out this year nintendo announced
today that pokemon sun and moon is
coming out the game will be available
this holiday on 3ds a new trailers also
appeared it's awesome no details were
shared regarding gameplay elements for
the first time in franchise history sun
and moon will offer traditional and
simplified chinese as language options
additionally they will come with Pokemon
bank functionality allowing players to
move Pokemon wirelessly from pokemon red
blue and yellow as well as Omega Ruby
alpha sapphire X Y to Sun and Moon bonus
tomorrow februari 27th is the 20th
anniversary of the Pokemon franchise
happy birthday Pokemon there's a 24-hour
animation live stream event on Twitch so
be sure to check that out so our fourth
puppy is justine and our fourth news
story all the free games you get
PlayStation Plus account in March Sony's
confirmed the PlayStation Plus freebies
for the month there's six games total
including two for playstation 4 ps4
users with a subscription can pick up
bro force which is the one voted for by
you guys and galaxy meanwhile the last
guy and super stardust HD will be
offered on ps3 playstation vita will be
able to pick up flame over and reality
fighters you can grab the current slate
of PS Plus games like nom nom galaxy and
grid Autosport until march first our
fish puppy is Anakin oh and our fifth
story is that there were mortal kombat
secret menus discovered 20 years later
the original Mortal Kombat games were
subject to many players speculating
about their secrets some were true and
some were super lies however it was only
recently discovered that the original
games contained secret menus the cutting
room floor a website dedicated
unearthing secret content video games
uncovered the secret ejb menus these
were named after the series creator ed
boon now youtuber your MK arcade source
has showcased the menus on their Channel
the secret menu contain things like
diagnostic tests coin bookkeeping and
character endings the first two mortal
kombat game menus have an item called
pelo which your MK arcade source
believes as a list of people at boone
wanted to say hi to ultimate mortal
kombat 3 secret menu features the
ability to enable hidden characters
fatality demonstrations and an
overwhelmingly difficult Galaga type
game to access these menus you'll need
to put special code in on the cabinet we
have these listed on our site in case
you know of a cabinet and you want to
try it out and our bonus puppy is ducky
let me know in the comments below who
your favorite puppy is C Mon they're all
cute though and those are our top 5 news
stories of the week thanks a lot guys
you